as a director does netflix pay you
residuals
no and i don't know if that's true for
for every film
of course um but at least at the level
i'm at and with these films no there's
no residuals
um for that and i don't know if that's
the same for actors so i think actors
with sag and all of that obviously
there's a much different
probably deal there trying to remember
because there was there was negotiations
for streaming at some point i'm trying
to
i'm bad with keeping up on all the
latest uh information with that
but for myself no if a group of young
filmmakers came to you
and said they wanted to make movies only
for netflix
what would you advise them in terms of
story production
budget um yeah for netflix that's
interesting because it's
kind of this ever moving thing so
uh in in what trends on there um
i would say that netflix
at least in my experience or my
perception of it
is it is a little bit more
kind of an algorithm based thing you
know what i'm saying like it's
it's uh almost like a youtube but not i
mean not the same as youtube but
but very much like what uh
attracts viewership and uh and things
like that is a little bit more
it is constantly changing so that's a
hard one to to figure out i think
um netflix also does things on
all spectrums i mean they have movies
that are made at a couple million they
have movies that are made at 100 million
so it's really hard to kind of
pinpoint exactly uh what to say would
work to help you get
get it sold onto netflix other than just
you know
try and make stories that uh
uh resonate with
with an audience um obviously try and
make it
the it's gotta be of a certain standard
certain quality
um so i think those are goals to shoot
for
um but
yeah that's a tough one to say i think
there's probably
the two spectrums of of budget levels
um you've got the ones that you probably
want to keep
you know under a certain amount because
then then the sale to netflix
makes sense um because if you
make it for too much you're never going
to get that amount back if that makes
sense
but then on the flip side if you've got
you know big name actors in it
you know whoever that might be a will
smith or something then
obviously those numbers completely
change so you could make a
50 million dollar movie and still sell
it and it would make sense on netflix
but again i think a lot of those are
more of the netflix originals as well
that they're willing to put in that kind
of uh um
that kind of a commitment um for a big
big movie like that
um i don't really see them going after
the
you know more low low budget stuff like
the sub 1 million dollar films but again
i could be wrong
because i just don't know all the inner
inner workings of it
um but
they definitely also have parameters in
place
for uh your gear so i'd say
first and foremost if that's really your
goal probably the best advice i could
say was find out the specs that they
require because they actually do really
require
certain specs like i believe it has to
be shot in 4k
minimum and they literally have gear
approved they have a gear approved list
for netflix like
what you can film on what cameras they
approve
and things like that so they actually do
have some technical aspects
that you could kind of uh
um lack of a better word screw yourself
out of ever getting a netflix deal if
you don't meet certain parameters
again i don't know exactly what all
those are and they do change
but i do know that there are
certain like i believe the black magic
pocket cameras are actually approved for
netflix
so something on that level which is
still affordable
uh and and uh you know
to a certain degree are still at enough
quality level to be approved
by netflix i believe again don't quote
me on any of this but
um uh but there are certain ones that
aren't for whatever reason it doesn't
meet the specs
um maybe the color space isn't deep
enough doesn't have enough
bits or whatever um so that would be the
starting point
like make sure you check with that kind
of stuff and
and and make your goals of filming it to
meet those certain parameters
um other than that i think they
uh they obviously
um you know uh stream
such a wide variety of things you can
see i've got very kind of
family-friendly pg movies in lady driver
and roped
that actually were really successful on
netflix they trended they were on the
popular lists
roped i think climbed as high as like 22
on like most popular film on netflix
uh and it's it's a very much uh
pg family friendly and then you have the
opposite end of the spectrum
where you've got the you know uh very
gritty
dark you know the the stranger things
and the and those kinds of shows that
are
extremely successful so i think they
really are open to a variety of
of uh genres and styles of filmmaking
so it's really hard to pinpoint you know
what would work and what wouldn't work
on there
but obviously check the specs that's
where i'd start
and then make a good story and uh and
be as creative and get the best quality
that you can
and are those specs available to the
public on their website
or so you know where i've read about it
as has been more in like the
um like film gear
uh like websites and publications like
that
um i have seen like hey this camera is
actually
you know meets the meets you know
netflix approved specs
i personally never have seen a sheet or
whatever that says what those specs are
but um and i've never searched it up but
i have
read about it like i said in in
those you know like 4kshooter.com or
something like that you know
one of those uh one of those websites uh
um i've read about uh the different
cameras and if they meet the spec like
this red komodo that just came out
it got netflix approved so you can use
this new red camera that's a
it's kind of a much smaller red and it i
believe it shoots 6k
so it doesn't do the 8k that the newer
reds or the other reds
are doing now like we shot uh we filmed
uh california christmas on a red geminis
that are 8k
um and we we shot uh
with some vintage lenses though we had
these vintage anamorphic kawas that we
shot on
on uh on this 8k new camera i always i
actually really love
trying to meld old and new that's
something that really kind of excites me
um even to the point that uh which i
have been known to search you know ebay
for some vintage style lenses that might
not fit on
my cameras but i will figure out a way
to adapt them
even with metal files out in the garage
i'm shaving down
you know mounting parts to make them fit
together and i love experimenting with
that kind of stuff
uh so anytime i get that opportunity i
do it
this was the second film that i took
really like vintage
uh anamorphic style lenses and put them
match them with the
with the newer cameras and i love the
results i think it's
uh just makes for really interesting
imagery and
um uh and i just love anamorphic as well
if i had a choice i would film
everything on
anamorphic just a quality to it that
that excites me
you